we're looking for a new apartment to
move into right
so let's look outside the solar system
do you think
you've you've spoken about exoplanets as
well
do you think there's possible homes out
there for us
uh outside of our solar system there are
lots and lots of homes
possible homes i mean there there's a
planetary system around nearly every
star you see in the sky
and one in five of those is thought to
have a roughly
earth-like planet yeah and that's a
relatively new
yeah it's a music i mean the kepler
satellite which was flying around
uh above earth's atmosphere was able to
monitor the brightness of stars with
exquisite detail and they could detect
planets crossing the line of sight
between
us and the star thereby dimming its
light
for a short time ever so slightly and
it's it's amazing so there are now
thousands and thousands
of these exoplanet candidates of which
something like 90 percent are probably
genuine exoplanets and you have to
remember that
only about one percent of stars
have their planetary system oriented
edge on to your line of sight
which is what you need for this transit
method to work
right some arbitrary angle won't work
and certainly perpendicular
uh to your line of sight that is in the
plane of the sky won't work because the
the planet is orbiting the star and
never crossing your line of sight
so the fact that um you know they found
planets orbiting about one percent of
the stars that they looked at in this
field of 150 plus
thousand stars they found planets around
one percent you then multiply
by the inverse of one percent which is
you know right
one percent is about how many what the
fraction of the
of the stars that have their planetary
system oriented the right way
and that already back of the envelope
calculation tells you that
of order 50 to 100 of all stars have
planets okay and then
they've been finding these earth-like
planets etcetera etcetera so there are
many potential homes
the problem is getting there okay so
then
a typical bright star sirius the
brightest star in the sky
maybe not a typical bright star but it's
8.7
light years away okay so uh
that's that means the light took 8.7
years
to reach us we're seeing it as it was
about nine years ago
okay so then you know you ask how long
would a rocket take to get there
at earth's escape speed which is 11
kilometers per second
okay and it turns out it's about a
quarter of a million years
okay now that's 10 000 generations okay
let's say a generation of humans is 25
years right
so you'd need this colony of people
that is able to sustain itself all their
food
all their waste disposal all their water
all the recycling of everything
for 10 000 generations they have to
commit themselves
to living on this vehicle
right i just don't see it happening
what i see potentially happening if we
avoid self-destruction
intentional or unintentional here on
earth
is that machines will do it robots that
can essentially hibernate they don't
need to do much of anything
for a long long time as they're
traveling and moreover
if some energetic charged particles some
cosmic ray
hits the circuitry it fixes itself right
machines can do this
uh i mean it's a form of
artificial intelligence you just tell
the thing fix yourself basically and
then
when you land on the pro on the planet
start producing
copies of yourself initially from
materials that were perhaps sent or you
just have a bunch of copies there
and then they set up you know factories
with which to do this i mean this is
very very futuristic but
it's much more feasible i think
than sending flesh and blood over
interstellar distances a quarter of a
million years to even the nearest stars
you're subject to all kinds of charged
particles and radiation
you have to you know shield yourself
really well that's by the way one of the
problems of going to mars is that
it's not a three-day journey like going
to the moon you're out there
for the better part of a year or two and
you're exposed to
lots of radiation you know which
typically doesn't do well
with living tissue right or living
tissue doesn't do well with the
radiation
you